hey youtubers is Charlie so during my
city of blood video I asked you to
submit all your biggest questions about
the episode in the rest of the season so
I picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question
it looks like the Starling City Weather
Service is predicting fire tornadoes
with a heavy chance of apocalypse if
you're finding me for the first time I
typically do Q&A videos like this just
so I can feature you know fun comments
that you guys leave that I think are
really awesome it's also a good
opportunity to follow up on big you know
WTF things that happen during the week
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even doing a bunch of spider-man
stuff tomorrow morning so time for
questions careful for spoilers from
episode 21 if you haven't seen it yet
but here we go number one
Sven - Sven - asks what do you think
that Oliver will call the new foundry so
I'm hoping that he'll call it the arrow
cave in a twist of what is reaction to
Felicity calling the arrow cave was
earlier you know whenever Roy joined
remember he was all like we don't call
it that I really like for him to have a
moment where he caves you know sorry for
the wordplay and just calls it the new
arrow cave the thing about the show is
that Oliver is always the straight man
that's a comedy term in a comedy sketch
you know you have like two or more
people they'll always be one person
who's not in on the joke and they'll
just react to other people being silly
Saturday Night Live does it all the time
on arrow that straight person is Oliver
he's always reacting to Felicity being
really silly so I think it'd be a nice
twist if he did something really silly
and Felicity reacted to him so thus I
really want to see him call it the new
arrow cave question number two kofi asks
do you think that Merlyn will take Thea
under his wing and save her he'll
definitely rescue her but because I
don't think that Willa Holland is
leaving the show I don't think she's
gonna go with him in order to get that
Merlyn Thea Artemis storyline she'd have
to go away because John Barrowman isn't
coming back to the show full time so
you'd have to have Willa leave the show
in the way that Barry Allen left the
show to go back to Central City I think
that Willa is still gonna be on the show
full time in season 3 so she's probably
not gonna go with him that doesn't mean
that Merlyn is going to die or that he's
not going to come back in season 3 but
characters are always way more
interesting when they're haunted by evil
parents and now that Moira is dead and
you know that evil parent is gone Merlyn
is basically gonna step in and fill that
role I do totally think that Merlyn is
gonna pop in at least once or twice next
season or at least be referenced in
conversation
Laurel always references Tommy whenever
she's talking to all
so why wouldn't the always reference
Malcolm you know in the future whenever
she talks to Oliver question number
three
Austin asks do you think that Nyssa will
die in the finale and that will cause
Rachael Ghul to unleash on Starling city
now I think Katrina law is too precious
of an actress for them to get rid of
she's like the best representation that
they have of the league raesha and Talia
that they would get you know without
having to deal with all those
complicated continuity issues that's why
you don't see more characters jumping
from show to show even Marvel only does
it a little bit so anytime they want to
use the league as a story device they
can just bring her back as for her
relationship with Oliver and Starling
city we'll have to wait and see what
ends up happening in the finale but
essentially you know she doesn't hate
Oliver she just treats him like you
would treat someone who's dating your ex
you know with a lot of content I do
think that she understands what Oliver
is trying to do and accepts it so
they're not enemies flat out they're
more like frenemies I do like the idea
of Oliver creating his own enemies like
the Huntress and Slade although the
Huntress really wasn't his enemy Slade
you could say is more of an enemy of
circumstance - the only reason he's
doing this is because of the mirakuru so
what's the cure him his entire
motivations gonna be gone I do think
there will be another villain at some
point that Oliver will be directly
responsible for creating remember back
to the Michael Keaton Batman in his
relationship with the Jack Nicholson
Joker you know Joker kills parents
creates Batman Batman dumps Joker in vat
of chemicals you know Joker goes crazy
on the city question number four Oliver
Queen asks do you think that brother
blood will have a change of heart before
the finale yeah whenever Oliver was
sitting down at dinner with him and made
him face facts about Slade there was
like a moment of hesitation on his face
but all that being considered I think
he's committed himself to the cause he's
basically drinking his own mirakuru
kool-aid remember that shot of Laurel
with the bow from next week's episode I
think that she is going to have the
pleasure of killing him I don't care how
she does it but if she did kill him with
Mo it would be pretty freaking sweet I
think of any of the villains end up
dying this season he's gonna be the one
Laurel has gotten pretty dark
she's broken the law wiretapping him
without a warrant used extortion to get
her job back and I totally think that
she's willing to kill him to save Oliver
and the rest of team arrow I also think
whatever she does in these last two
episodes to help save Oliver and team
arrow is gonna inform her character in
season 3 it's gonna be part of her major
arc
question number five sour rooster asks
if Sarah dies do you think that Nyssa
would become the season 3 villain no I
don't think that's the case but if Sarah
does end up dying I do think that Nyssa
will flip out and kill a bunch of people
probably mostly mirakuru soldiers I
don't think that she would hold Sarah's
death against Oliver she wouldn't waste
her time on him the league is from Nanda
Parbat but they are an international
organization with operations going on
all over the planet
so Starling city is like a speck of dust
in their grand design I would like to
see her fight Slade though because she
had Oliver were essentially an even
match so she would do at least as good
against Slade as Oliver did which I
guess isn't saying a lot because every
time Oliver has fought him he's got his
butt kicked question number 6 macho man
asks did you see that T statue in
brother Bloods office how soon could a
Teen Titans spin-off occur and who would
be the villain so right now they're just
trying to get the flash show ordered to
series we'll know in about two weeks
whether or not that's gonna happen you
know by the middle of May there's like a
99% chance that it's gonna happen based
on what people inside the CW have been
saying if the flash TV show ends up
being really successful then they'll
start targeting new shows to develop
right now I think there's a much better
chance of Suicide Squad becoming the
next show after the flash just because
they spend so much time on arrow
developing those characters and arrow
itself does not depend on those
characters being present so like Teen
Titans would mean they'd have to get rid
of Roy and Thea or anyone else that they
use I don't see the show getting rid of
wil Holland or Colton Haynes anytime
soon so no Teen Titans for the
foreseeable future that doesn't mean
it'll never happen you know Never Say
Never but probably Suicide Squad would
be the next one question number seven
pastor will asks what do you think he
meant when Oliver said they started with
just those three and they needed to get
back to that so I think he was talking
more about the finale I think in the end
it's gonna be just those three against
Slade I don't think that Ravager and
brother blood are gonna make it to that
very final fight you know like the last
fight question number 8 Erik Jabba asks
who do you think Isabel rochev is
hallucinating since she's full of
mirakuru now too so that's actually a
really good question it seems like
usually most people end up hallucinating
people they either had sexual
relationships with or had sexual
feelings for in the case of Slade in the
case of Isabel though I think she's
actually hallucinating Diggle just
because he's the one that
visited her final trauma on her as in
killed her and it seems like her main
goal right now is to just get revenge
for that it's a really interesting thing
about Isabel's character as well as
brother blood is that they essentially
have what they want you know he was
promised the city she was promised Queen
industries and so now they're basically
just along for the ride it's kind of
like they won the lottery and now
they're just trying to figure out what
to spend all the cash on so I do think
that we'll see some moments of
hesitation on both their faces before
the finale question number nine jerry
chan asks do you think that Laurel could
become Artemis instead of Black Canary I
totally think that's a possibility that
would actually be pretty awesome
but I think that's a character arc they
would have to wait for season three
she's definitely going to be a more
active member of team arrow next season
but I think most of her time will be
spent in a support role like Felicity
Chu probably trained just because she
seems less physically awkward than
Felicity but she'll never be as vicious
as Sarah what I'm really hoping is is
that Sarah does survive the finale and
ends up you know going back to the
league with Nyssa but that she and
Oliver kind of share some responsibility
and training Laurel we probably won't
see a lot of that on screen but I am
expecting us to get at least a few you
know beau training scenes with Oliver
and Laurel next season I definitely
think that team arrow needs more girl
power to balance out all the dudes it's
turning into a bit of a sausage fest
right now and as much as felicity is
Oliver's conscience Laurel is more of an
equal you know not so much in a physical
sense but in that she wields as much
authority as this character I think that
Laurel kind of exists in the middle of
that spectrum between you know super
brainy and super strong so we'll
probably see a little bit of both from
her next season question number 10 John
asks do you think the Suicide Squad will
help deal with the mirakuru army yeah
there is no way the team arrow is gonna
be able to get all those people by
themselves the image we saw of Nyssa and
the finale implies that the league won't
be back until that episode episode 23
which means Oliver is gonna have to get
more help next week in episode 22 and we
were literally just at Argus in the last
episode so I totally expect her to come
back and one last bonus question jy 9:01
2's is Roy coming back in the next
episode and will he be cured so
Frankenstein has to wake up at some
point and I mean I feel like they've
been teasing it enough I think once they
get the cure from STAR Labs they'll fix
Roy first and then figure out how to
deliver it to the rest of those soldiers
I know a lot of you have also been
asking me about Royce you know official
suit like his red Arsenal suit and
Stephen Amell did make some comments
earlier this year at a convention where
he said that there would be another you
know superhero getting a suit on the
show but I think based on recent
developments he was talking about
Ravager in order for Roy to get a suit
Oliver would have to make it and right
now he's underneath a pile of concrete
trapped with a bunch of super soldiers
so he's not gonna be sowing any red
leather pants anytime soon so thank you
so much for submitting bonus questions
these are always a ton of fun to do and
remember there's only two more episodes
left my next bonus video will post
before episode of 22 airs you know next
Wednesday be sure to subscribe to get it
and feel free to leave me suggestions
for what you want those are the bonus
videos to be about so right now click
here to get my review of the episode and
click here to learn all about the new
Justice League movie they just announced
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you tomorrow
high fives
you